avec beau julien schell dames bonjour
julien berger pauline et donc la presse
britannique évidemment revient
longuement sur le vote de défiance qui a
visé hier boris johnson le premier
ministre on à dia a sauvé sa tête mais
ce vote risque de laisser des traces
effectivement avec une presse qui tire à
boulet rouge sur boris johnson malgré
cette courte victoire on va commencer
par le times lui qui dépeint le premier
ministre comme un vainqueur blessé avec
la une à la une le visage grave du
premier ministre pourquoi bhl et c'est
bien parce que vous le disiez il ne doit
sa survie politique à une courte
majorité 211 députés contre 148 issus de
son propre parti le désaveu est totale
écrit le quotidien qui je précise et
d'obédiences conservateurs pour lé daily
mirror et bien c'est plus simple la fête
est finie évidemment référence au parti
auquel on fait auquel a participé le
premier ministre fait interdits durant
le confinement pour le tabloïd le compte
à rebours est même lancé jusqu'au
prochain départ de beaux jo
officiellement le parlement ne pourra
pas suscite déposer une nouvelle motion
de défiance contre boris johnson avant
un an mais pour le quotidien le premier
ministre est vraiment trop fragilisés et
il aura du mal à asseoir son autorité
avec une si faible majorité justement
avec un bot aussi étriqué il s'agit tout
simplement d'une humiliation pour deux
gardiennes le quotidien classé à gauche
ne s'est jamais ne s'est jamais montré
très tendre envers boris johnson tout
comme dit independent' qui pose une
question jusqu'à quand boris johnson
va-t-il tenir le quotidien critique le
fait que le premier ministre s'accroche
au pouvoir en dépit de toutes les
polémiques qui ont tranché entaché son
mandat depuis qu'il est arrivé au
tendeng street voilà pour la presse
britannique la presse étrangère revient
aussi longuement sur cette victoire plus
qu'un truc et julien je vous donne un
exemple très symbolique qui illustre
liste l'état d'esprit de la presse
étrangère on va prendre la direction des
états unis avec le washington post et
cette photo d'un boris johnson
totalement désabusé surtout cette
affirmation la une la question n'est
plus de savoir s'il va partir mais quand
avec deux exemples dans le passé
britannique fin 2018 theresa may
subissent est elle aussi un vote de
défiance qu'elle avait remportée avec
63% de votre favorable pour elle à voile
s'était encore margaret thatcher idole
des conservateurs qui avait remporté le
même type de vin avec 54% d'opinions
favorables sauf qu'à chaque fois les
deux femmes avaient démissionné peu de
temps après parce qu'elle était tout
simplement trop fragilisé au sein de
parti est-ce que ce qui ce qui attend
beaux jo le juge s'interroge le journal
premier test à la fin du mois avec des
élections partielles à haut risque voilà
donc pour ce phénix en tout cas pour
l'instant politique britannique il y à
50 ans julien une photo emblématique
devenait le symbole des horreurs de la
guerre du vietnam on la découvre
derrière vous une partie de la presse
internationale revient aujourd'hui sur
son anniversaire pour cet anniversaire
effectivement photo immensément célèbre
et on sait le site de commercer chaîne
se pose la question comment une photo
s'inscrit-elle dans la mémoire
collective six articles que je veux dont
je vous conseille vivement la lecture
avec cette photo qui représente des
enfants vietnamiens apeuré fuyant une
attaque au napalm et avec au centre
cette fillette qui a fait le tour du
monde à l'époque qui aujourd'hui encore
est une faute extrêmement connue ce qui
est complètement nue pourquoi et bien
parce qu'elle vient juste d'enlever ses
vêtements qui ont été brûlées par le
napalm la photo des hippies a aussitôt
été publié en une des journaux du monde
entier pour illustrer les horreurs d'une
guerre qui était déjà à l'époque très
très critiqué et cet anniversaire est
l'occasion pour la petite fille donc que
l'on voit sur cette photo qui avait 10
ans à l'époque et qui en a 60
aujourd'hui et qui a donc survécu avec
ces brûlures de revenir sur ce lourd
héritage oui kim book qui vit aux
etats-unis aujourd'hui a déjà beaucoup
témoigné sur cet épisode de sa vie elle
cite encore aujourd'hui elle dit le
napalm vous colle à la peau qui provoque
des brûlures et des douleurs horrible
qui durent toute votre vie elle raconte
histoire aussi l'histoire de nick le
photographe qui a pris la photo et qui
lui a sauvé la vie juste avoir après
avoir pris ce cliché photo qui est lui a
aussi permis d'obtenir les soins
nécessaires pour prendre en charge le
traitement de ses brûlures à l'époque
peu d'enfants qui avaient été victimes
de cette attaque avait pu arriver à
temps à l'hôpital elle témoigne aussi de
la difficulté de porter le lourd lourd
héritage de cette photo qui le rappelle
le traumatisme de l'époque mais elle
n'aspire même si elle aspire encore
aujourd'hui à une vie disons anonyme
elle reconnaît le pouvoir de cette photo
devenue le symbole des horreurs d'une
guerre ça fait 50 ans je ne suis plus la
petite fille au napalm
à lire dans le new york times est donc
un témoignage du lien qui fait écho
malheureusement à la guerre en ukraine
qui a débuté il ya plus de cent jours
maintenant avec sur le plan diplomatique
une inquiétude et celle d'une désunion
des pays de l'union européenne
effectivement pauline les propos d'
emmanuel macron sur son appel à ne pas
humilier la russie ont fait beaucoup
réagir et la dernière réaction vient de
la première ministre estonienne kaia
callas dans le guardian trouver à tout
prix je cite une solution diplomatique
pour un pays qui s'est rendu coupable de
crimes de guerre n'est pas une issue
possible dit elle nous avons déjà fait
cette erreur avec la géorgie et la
crimée on ne peut pas recommencer fin de
citation autre point de vue radicalement
différent cette fois-ci ça vient de
république tchèque dans le quotidien
hospodarske noviny
qui pose une question qui peut fâcher et
bien est-ce que la question à un retour
à la paix ne serait pas tout simplement
une session de territoire ukrainien à la
russie question cynique voire
outrageante partagé en coulisses par
quelques voix européenne et surtout
question proposé publiquement à kiev par
un vieux roublard de la diplomatie
américaine henry kissinger mais pas sûr
qu'après trois mois de guerre 14
millions de déplacés et un pays en
partie détruits et les ukrainiens
entendre cet appel qui ressemblerait à
une sorte de victoire de la russie tout
autre chose enfin du foot et ce nul
concédé hier par l'équipe de france de
foot service minimum c'est au minimum ce
qu'on demandait aux bleus après leur
défaite surprise ce week-end face au
danemark avec une équipe très de france
très remaniée qui aurait même pu
remporter la victoire sans un penalty
accordé dans les tout derniers instants
un partout donc face à la croatie on
s'arrête là julien on se retrouve tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure